REAL-TIME FACT-CHECKING.
>> TESTING THE FACT-CHECKERS.
>> Greg: SADLY THE
ANTICIPATION OVERWHELMS THE
PAYOFF.
THE MEDIA SEEMED SO DEFLATED
THEY HAD TO TURN TO THEIR
LATE-NIGHT BOOTY CALL:
COLLUSION.
THEY TRIED TO FACT-CHECK BUT IT
WAS HARD BECAUSE THE STATS WERE
REAL AND SOBERING, LIKE WHEN
DONALD TRUMP DETAILED THE MURDER
OF A YOUNG POLICE OFFICER, A
DISMEMBERED NEIGHBOR, GANG
MEMBERS STABBING A YOUNG GIRL TO
DEATH.
THOSE ARE FACTS.
HARD TO QUESTION THE 266,000
ARRESTS OF ALIENS WITH CRIMINAL
RECORDS, 100,000 ASSAULTS,
30,000 SEX CRIMES, VIOLENT
KILLINGS, THE ONE IN THREE WOMEN
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED IN THE TRACK
THROUGH MEXICO OR THE 20,000
MIGRANT CHILDREN ILLEGALLY
BROUGHT TO THE U.S. LAST MONTH,
MANY USED BY COYOTES AND GANGS.
THOSE WERE FACTS IGNORED BY THE
MEDIA AND OF COURSE BY MA AND
PAUL CATTELL.
TRUMP HAD PUT THEM IN A
FACT-CHECK BOX.
THE VAST OVERREACH, THERE IS A
BONA FIDE EMERGENCY ON THE
BORDER.
SAID "THE WASHINGTON POST" DAYS
AGO.
WHEN TRUMP BROUGHT UP THIS
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS, THE SAME
PAPER CALLED HIM A LIAR.
WAS IT BECAUSE HE USED THEIR
ANALYSIS?
NO WONDER NOBODY PAYS ATTENTION
TO THESE SO-CALLED
FACT-CHECKERS.
THEY DON'T EVEN TRUST WHAT THEY
SAY TO THEMSELVES AND NEITHER DO
WE.
THOUGHTS COME A DAY NOW WELL,...
>> Greg: THANKS.
JESSE.
THEY SAID WE DIDN'T HAVE TIME.
>> Dana: SO MUCH BUILD UP TO
SPEECH THAT THE TIME IT WAS
GIVEN, IT WAS ANTICLIMACTIC.
IF THE PRESIDENT HAD ANNOUNCED A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY, IT WOULD'VE
BEEN LIKE WOW.
THAT'S NEWS.
IF YOU'RE COVERING THIS EVERY
DAY, THERE WAS REALLY NOTHING
NEW BUT HE PUT IT ALL TOGETHER
AND ONE PLACE.
IT WAS GEARED TOWARD TO THE
BROADER PUBLIC DOESN'T PAY
ATTENTION TO THIS STUFF ALL THE
TIME.
WHAT JOURNALISTS DO IS
FACT-CHECKING.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO SPECIFICALLY
SAY I'M GOING TO FACT-CHECK NOW.
YOU JUST DO YOUR JOB BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT YOU DO.
>> Greg: WHAT I FOUND, EMILY,
THEY PORTRAYED THEIR REBUTTAL AS
A FACT-CHECK.
THEY DISAGREED WITH WHAT HE
SAID.
THEN THEY WOULD GO, OH, BUT IT'S
COMING THROUGH PORT OF ENTRY IS.
THAT'S PROBABLY BECAUSE THERE'S
A WALL THAT KEPT THEM FROM GOING
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
THAT'S A REBUTTAL, NOT A
FACT-CHECK.
>> Emily: I THINK THERE WAS A
MISSED OPPORTUNITY TO GET OUT OF
BEING MIRED IN THE DETAILS AND
TALK ABOUT THE LARGER ISSUES AND
HOW IT WILL ROLLOUT IN TERMS OF
POLICY.
THE WHOLE POINT WAS TOMORROW THE
DEMOCRATS ARE MEETING HIM AT THE
WHITE HOUSE TO MAYBE COME TO AN
AGREEMENT WITHIN AN HOUR.
ACCURACY IS IMPORTANT BUT I
THINK IT BECAME ITS OWN FLURRY
AND KIND OF RIDICULOUS.
>> Greg: JESSE, I WANT TO
BRING UP, JOHN AT CNN, HE
TWEETED "THE VIEW FROM THE
OVAL OFFICE SEEMS TO BE MOST
DOCUMENTED MIGRANTS ARE
MURDERERS, DRUG DEALERS, THUGS
AND DRUG TRAFFICKERS."
TRUMP NEVER SAID THAT.
HE JUST WENT OVER STATISTICS.
THAT'S THEIR PROBLEM.
THEY ARE COMPLETELY BIASED.
THEY THINK THAT THEIR BIAS IS
SOMEHOW A SIEVE FOR
FACT-CHECKING.
>> Jesse: THEY WILL SAY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS COMMIT LESS
CRIMES THAN YOUR AVERAGE
AMERICAN CITIZEN.
THAT'S LIKE SAYING CRACK KILLS
LESS PEOPLE THAN HEROIN.
IT DOESN'T MEAN YOU DON'T FIGHT
THE CRACK ACADEMIC.
-- EPIDEMIC.
WHEN YOU REDUCE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, YOU WILL THEREFORE
REDUCE CRIME.
I ALSO DON'T LIKE WHEN THEY SAY
IT'S A MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
JUAN SAYS IN 2000, THERE WERE
100,000 ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSINGS
PER MONTH.
NOW THERE ARE 60,000 BORDER
CROSSINGS PER MONTH.
THAT'S LIKE SAYING MY HOME GOT
BROKEN INTO IN 2000 FIVE TIMES
AND NOW IT GETS BROKEN INTO
THREE TIMES.
IT DOESN'T MEAN YOU DON'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT SECURING YOUR
HOME.
THEY ARE TRYING TO IGNORE THE
PROBLEM.
ANOTHER STATISTIC THAT WAS
PRETTY AMAZING, TRUMP SAID LAST
NIGHT THAT ONE IN THREE WOMEN
WHEN THEY MAKE THE JOURNEY
NORTH, GETS RAPED WHEN THEY ARE
TRYING TO COME TO AMERICA.
THE FACT-CHECKERS SET ITS FOUR
AND FIVE WOMEN GET RAPED.
WHEN YOU ADD TO THE FACT THAT
THERE IS SICK KIDS BEING HELD
BECAUSE HE CAN'T SEND THE BACK
BECAUSE THEY'RE FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA AND THEY COME
FROM FAMILIES BECAUSE OF THE
LOOPHOLES, THAT THE ASSAULTS ON
BORDER PATROL AGENTS ARE UP 300%
AND OFFICER SINGH KILLED BY AN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT THE OTHER DAY.
TO SAY THAT IT'S A MANUFACTURED
CRISIS BUT GLOBAL WARMING IS A
REAL CRISIS, HOW MANY AMERICANS
HAVE DIED FROM GLOBAL WARMING,
JUAN?
HOW MANY, WILLIAMS?
HOW MANY?
ZERO.
>> Juan: I THINK YOUR BRAIN
MIGHT BE FRIED ON THE GLOBAL
WARMING.
HERE'S THE THING.
I AGREE WITH DANA.
I THINK JOURNALISTS SHOULD CHECK
FACTS FROM THESE POWERFUL PEOPLE
WHEN THEY SPEAK FROM THE BULLY
PULPIT.
>> Greg: NOT IF THEY ARE
BIASED.
>> Juan: THERE IS NO NEED FOR
BIAS.
CHECK THE FACTS.
THE WAY THAT YOU PRESENT THE
FACTS, THAT CROSSINGS ARE AT A
20-YEAR LOW.
IF IT'S AT A 20-YEAR LOW AND YOU
SAY IT STILL IS A CRISIS, THEN
WHAT HAPPENED WHEN THE
REPUBLICANS WERE IN CONTROL OF
EVERYTHING AND DID NOTHING ABOUT
THIS SO-CALLED CRISIS?
I THINK MOST PEOPLE, MAYBE LIKE
STORMY DANIELS SAID I PREFER
FOLDING LAUNDRY OR MAY BE LIKE
PEOPLE --
>> Dana: IS THAT WHAT YOU WERE
WATCHING JUAN?
>> Juan: SQUINTING AT THE
TELEPROMPTER.
IT JUST WASN'T HIM LAST NIGHT
AND HE MADE NO NEWS.
WHEN YOU THINK WHY FACT-CHECK, I
WILL TELL YOU WHY.
THIS GUY HAS BEEN DEMONIZING
PEOPLE WHO ARE IMMIGRANTS AND
THEN SAYING LIES ABOUT THOSE
IMMIGRANTS AND THEN HE GETS A
NATIONAL ADDRESS AND EVERYBODY
SAYS WE HAVE TO CHECK ON THE